el filibustero está en la mira de los
demócratas se trata de un procedimiento
parlamentario usado en el senado de los
eeuu desde el siglo 19 que permite a
cualquier senador bloquear o retrasar la
votación sobre una ley extendiendo el
debate hasta el cansancio el récord de
obstrucción lo ostenta el senador strom
thurmond que en 1957 habló por más de 24
horas para bloquear una ley de derechos
civiles la cámara alta- está conformada
por 100 senadores y aunque técnicamente
los 51 votos de una mayoría simple
permitirían aprobar un proyecto de ley
se necesitan 60 votos para iniciar o
finalizar el debate algo que ofrece al
partido minoritario la posibilidad de
bloquear la agenda de la mayoría pero a
medida que aumenta la polarización crece
también el uso de la amenaza del
filibustero sólo entre 2019 y 2020 hubo
casi 300 casos
el filibustero no es utilizado por los
republicanos para unir al senado sino
para separarlo aún más es usado como un
arma abusiva
en medio de una ola de restricciones
impulsadas por los republicanos tras la
derrota de donald trump en 2020 el
derecho al voto es el nuevo caballo de
batalla de los demócratas y cambiar las
reglas del senado se baraje entre las
posibilidades de
el rey que declare
hoy dejo claro que para proteger nuestra
democracia apoyo cambiar las reglas del
senado
cualquiera que sea la forma que deba
cambiarse para evitar que una minoría de
senadores bloquee la acción sobre los
derechos de voto
[Aplausos]
en este ser la aprobación de la ley de
derechos electorales john lewis y del
llamado for the people act es el
objetivo de la casa blanca ante el temor
de perder su muy estrecha mayoría en las
elecciones de 2022 sin embargo senadores
demócratas centristas como joe manchin o
krysten sinema han expresado
escepticismo quienes defienden el
filibustero califican la regla como
importante para el equilibrio de poder y
para proteger el poco bipartidismo que
queda en el legislativo